we got omar with a pot of gold all right
oh wow that's zoomed in
yeah
hey sorry about that i don't know how to
fix it but
uh hey what's going on rich um i just
want to ask
basically i'm 28 i'm uh happily married
i um i have a great wife who like runs
the home i i've been pretty good with
like being able to take control of the
home if that makes sense but
um my question is this i was able to
um get out of like 60 000 worth of debt
i dropped out of school three times i
kept trying to go back because my
parents kept forcing me but
i dropped out every single time
i was able to kind of start my own um
collectibles business and
i made uh around like uh uh my net worth
is around a million dollars
uh i have no debt uh
uh i just turned 28. good for you um i i
don't know about i don't i'm st i feel
like i'm stagnating
basically what i mean by that is like
uh i i always have to play defensive
with my spending
because i'm kind of worried i
i know it's being a little [ __ ] but i'm
kind of worried about um
like my business not
not sustaining the future i feel like i
got lucky because they inflated the
money supply so high
in the past two years that what are you
doing for a living right now man
i have a
collectibles business like i basically
trade high-end collectibles like
high-end comics watches um cards stuff
like that okay so you buy low sell high
you're doing watches comic books exactly
yeah and i can't scale that and i've
i've made like around a million dollars
but i don't know where to go from here
if that makes sense i
i feel like it's not like a five like a
lifelong business if that makes sense
i'm very good at it i'm very good at
trading like whatever it is i do i'm
very good at it
okay so like what are you asking like
how do i make the next million how to
make the next five million uh where do i
go from here if i have a bunch of money
like
should i just like buy a business should
i just uh i like look man i mean you
guys know i'm a crypto bro so i would
put a chunk of that into bitcoin
ethereum maybe maybe like one or two
other in the top ten that you know that
you really like i have i have like 200
in ethereum uh in btc i don't really do
ethereum but i have a 200 btc i just
yeah i mean i would diversify into a
couple others you know maybe
maybe pick top three to five that you
really like you know projects that you
really trust in that seem to have a lot
of support
so i so i put some money in that you
know for starters because i think that's
got a big bright future i mean you know
for me it's like
you know people get pissed off at the
crypto markets because you know they're
in the toilets right now but it's like
if you're buying crypto and you can't
hold it for five to ten years like if
you can't hold it to 2030 then why are
you buying it like you know what's the
matter be like you stupid or something
like you think you're gonna make quick
quick money the problem is there's a lot
of these nerds out there that are like
buy this obscure loser coin and you're
gonna ten thousand extra money and then
they try to you know recruit a bunch of
people to try to do the exact same thing
and then people end up getting burned so
um look you know it's a long-term game
you know for me it's like okay you know
when i need the crypto is it going to be
a 70-foot yacht or am i going to buy a
100-foot yacht right it's just a matter
of like what does the portfolio look
like then so definitely
lean a little bit more into that part
the real estate market i wouldn't touch
right now where do you live in the
states or canada toronto toronto yeah i
wouldn't touch the real estate market
here right now i got out of the real
estate market at the peak i had a couple
condos in corktown that i got rid of
um
so there's that um buy a business look
man i'm not a big fan of canada like if
you followed me for a while you know
that i want to get the [ __ ] out of here
i i do want to get out like taxes are
high there's way too much government
control the wokeness is out of control
it's just stupid i don't see it getting
any better so
my advice if you're a younger guy and
you've got the ability to maneuver and
you've got a business that's location
independent i'd start you know checking
out some other places that are going to
be friendlier to you that's what i would
be using you know time for right now is
like okay you know if you see canada on
the same you know trajectory that i do
with yeah i think i'm i'm like i'm a
free market capitalist like
like i would use some of that time and
money to set yourself up you know
somewhere else and maybe if there's a
business there that you like that you
want to buy you know buy it you know if
there's real estate there that you like
because it's a good market then do that
um but
for for a 28 year old with the kind of
money that you have and no family or or
kids
i would be using that time to get the
[ __ ] out of canada
okay
all right fair enough thanks buddy hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you